all right let's get into this so today
uh our opening slide is the free market
solution to a broken cost of capital
which is a awesome awesome uh title for
this uh let's get into first we've got
the percentage gdp a weighted average
global debt and as a percent of gdp what
are you looking at here
yeah so this is just uh the best chart i
could find uh seems to be a little bit
outdated but it's just basically
aggregate global debt it's an estimate
because there's not it's not really
known uh to be honest with without the
financial system works uh the euro
dollar system fractional reserve banking
but this is just basically a rough
estimate of total global debt uh and
some estimates from people that i speak
to say it's much higher around 400
trillion but either way um you know a
trillion is a million million so uh
quite a lot of debt out there um and you
know if we go to the next slide we can
kind of see uh what's kind of the
problem here uh when we're talking about
a free market solution uh and being
bitcoin being that uh so this is the
10-year us treasury bond um for those
that aren't really familiar the dollars
the world reserve currency um so the u.s
treasury bond and the yield off that is
basically um kind of the the
uh like free market rate or not free
market but the rate that the entire
world the entire financial system goes
off of um so this is kind of that uh
that bedrock that uh that the entire
global financial system operates on and
so you can see from 1981 uh all the way
to today uh the yields have been
basically down to the right a lot of
lower highs um and so with every kind of
financial crisis every every debt crisis
yields plummet um and you know the kind
of the credit binge continues um and
this is nominal yield so this is before
inflation um and then the next chart is
even a little bit scarier
[Music]
all right next one we've got the real
10-year treasury bond yield versus the
10-year tips what's this showing us
yeah so you can just kind of ignore the
tips but what the real yield is it's the
same chart that we just showed but
adjusted for inflation right so you can
think of this when you when you borrow
money uh you're paying an interest rate
and if you if you you know subtract the
inflation rate on that debt that you're
paying back what's that yield you're
paying on the debt and so right now uh
with the us treasury bond basically if
you buy the us's debt you give money to
the us government in exchange for an
interest and interest payment and
getting your money back at the end uh
right now on the annual basis you get
about a minus five percent return and
that's if cpi that's if the inflation
rate they're reporting is true and so
why is this a problem essentially
because not only you know are we talking
about the debt but every asset in the
world every asset has a valuation has a
market cap has a fair value it's being
valued off of a negative cost of capital
negative real yield um so whether you're
talking about apple stock or you know
baseball card business or anything um
it's being valued with uh basically a
cost of capital or a yield um where real
yields across the planet 300 trillion
dollars worth of assets um even more if
you're counting equities and real estate
and the whole nine yards probably five
six seven hundred trillion dollars worth
of value uh it's all being basically
valued with this distorted cost of
capital um because of central banking
and because of how far we are in this
kind of fia debt based monetary system
rates can't sustainably rise uh or else
the whole thing collapses um so we have
a problem uh and i think we have a
solution as well it's absolutely nuts to
think about how crazy this has gotten uh
your next slide here is uh bitcoin the
perpetual futures open interest uh what
is this showing us and why is this
important
yeah so um i just you know this whole
kind of slide deck this whole
presentation is is to help people kind
of understand uh one there's a big
problem out there and two a lot of
people throw around bitcoin as a
solution or you you'll hear digital gold
or uh you know bitcoin is is shorting
bonds and you hear all these sorts of
analogies but uh and especially with
bitcoin derivatives there's a lot of
confusion out there um because these
markets are really complex and they move
really fast um but really what what
bitcoin derivatives and what bitcoin the
bear asset uh which has no yield right
if you hold bitcoin in your cold storage
there is no return in bitcoin terms uh
you're just holding a digital bearer
asset uh but with bitcoin derivatives um
that that is actually starting to change
and so there's this whole complex new
world out there um that i believe will
in the coming decade or maybe two uh
disrupt this 300 trillion dollar bond
market ponzi so the perpetual futures
open interest uh perpetual futures
contract we've gone over it a couple
times but i get a lot of dms especially
after your shows pop and people are
asking me uh to explain it a little bit
further and so you know i figured we
could break it down a little bit a
perpetual futures contract is just a
futurist market uh that never expires
and just rolls over and so there's
speculators that are betting on the
price of bitcoin to go up or down uh
through longer shorts and currently that
that market um is about you know 10 to
20 billion dollars give or take um so
it's still pretty small when you're
thinking about you know the 100 to you
know 500 trillion dollar asset pi um but
this market has seen incredible growth
over the last couple years and i think
we can expect that going forward do you
think that it can continue to grow
materially from here or is this kind of
like the maybe not the top of the market
uh but definitely like it's harder to go
kind of exponential from where we are
like there was such major growth how
much bigger could this market get
yeah so right now bitcoins valued at
about give or taking 900 billion dollars
um you know a lot of people have a lot
of different opinions um and i think in
terms of percentage growth on a relative
basis it's a lot harder for bitcoin to
say 10x like it did in a year and say
2013 uh
you know compared to today when they
would take
you know hundreds of billions
like a trillion tens of trillions of
dollars for that to occur again of
capital in flight but i i would suspect
that um you know 100 trillion dollars
you know valuing bitcoin at uh 500 000
um is uh wait that's five million i'm
sorry uh is is basically what i would
perceive to be uh relatively fair fair
value uh when you consider uh just the
monetary truths and and the big problem
in the world today right when i when i
say when people say what solution does
bitcoin solve i tell them the biggest
problem in the world the broken cost of
capital um no other no other market can
no other uh you know product or service
or or i guess protocol can solve a 500
trillion dollar problem um you know it's
the biggest problem in the world today
so when we go when we look at the actual
futures funding rate what is the
difference here like why is this
important to you
yeah so here we're talking about the
cost of capital and essentially what
bitcoin derivatives are right is we have
this native bare asset bitcoin with no
yields and now we have a future in the
market built on top of it and there's
people that are betting on the prices to
go down or up um and with every in a
perpetual futures market and in any
futures market
for every long for every buyer there's a
seller right there's a contractual
obligation um and so depending uh in the
bitcoin and futures market um there's no
there's never more longs or shorts but
these
these players these speculators can
drive the price up or down
so if they're driving if say speculators
in futures market are driving the price
higher than the the spot market price
say the price on coinbase
well what's going to happen is there's
going to be a funding rate applied to to
basically dis-incentivize or to tether
this this uh futures market price to the
actual indexed market or to the spa
market so if there's a if speculators
are really bidding the price of that
perpetual futures market uh contract up
we're going to see his funding's
positive so i applied a seven day moving
average to this funding rate over the
last two years and what do you see right
at the beginning of say say february of
2020
the funding rate every eight hours was
zero point eight eight percent uh but on
an annualized basis that was ninety six
percent so what does that mean it was
saying you know over a seven day period
uh longs were paying shorts ninety six
percent
to be to just to hold their position
right so essentially uh if you were just
uh uh you know a market participant with
some bitcoin you could just go short
bitcoin with just a small percentage of
your staff just be market neutral if you
wanted to and you could harvest uh 96
percent yield in the bitcoin futures
market right and so i get people don't
want to short bitcoin but what is what
this is saying is that the cost of
capital in this market is not centrally
planned there's no board or committee um
and it's entirely free market dependent
um so this happens in the long and short
side and there's massive liquidations
that often occur right
but but really what this is saying is
that we have this native cost of capital
that isn't subject to any just border
committee or central planning market
it's completely completely open and free
speaking of those liquidations you have
the futures long liquidations uh and it
looks like things were real crazy back
in the beginning of uh 21 but uh kind of
cooled off towards the end of the year
yeah so i threw this up here just to
kind of show uh what happens when um
dislocations occur right so if you think
about uh like the financial crisis of oa
or 2020 um every time that there's a 20
30 maybe 40 draw down in traditional
markets what happens um you know the
lender of last resort comes in they bail
everybody out you know wait they bought
all the bad debt off the the bank's
balance sheets uh and pumped a bunch of
money into the system to keep it afloat
in bitcoin uh there's the utxo set
there's a the full nodes that are
enforcing a hard cap supply uh and there
is no lender or of last resort you
either have bitcoin you have enough
collateral or you don't uh and so uh if
if all of a sudden that margin call
comes in in bitcoin or in crypto in
these derivative markets it's not called
the margin call it's called a
liquidation uh basically uh your account
gets marked to zero and you lost your
holdings um and so you know this is this
is in steep contrast to the legacy
system where often collateral is
rehydrated and when you know a lot of
market participants are all hurting at
once a lender of last resort comes in
and you know bails the system out and
this is you know exactly the opposite of
what we saw or what we see in bitcoin
all the time where these huge volatile
moves are you know occur on a regular
basis and any dislocations are wiped out
and so this cost of capital and bitcoin
although very variable um is entirely
free and open um and so bitcoin right
now is 900 billion um aggregate futures
open interest which we'll show on the
next slide is about 20 billion right
really small it's about two percent of
the market cap
but what happens when bitcoin is in a
trillion dollar asset and it's a 10
trillion or 100 trillion dollar asset uh
and this futures market is uh 200
billion or a two trillion dollar market
uh with with a floating cost of capital
um and i suspect that it's really going
to force the hand of
all of these central banks around the
world who you know centrally plan their
cost of capital centrally plan these
interest rates uh i think this will be a
kind of a forcing mechanism uh almost a
check on the irresponsibility of central
planners
got it and then when we start to look at
the annualized rolling basis what is
this showing us
so this is just similar to the perpetual
swaps we have quarterly uh futures
markets so say march of 2022 uh there's
a bitcoin futures contract for that
right so right now bitcoins say at 47
000 the march 2022 contract could trade
at say 48 000 or 49 000 and so if i was
just interested in capturing a yield
right like there's 300 trillion dollars
of of fiat denominated debt out there
chasing one to three percent nominal
yields right there's 30 trillion dollars
of government debt that's all that's all
basically at max getting two percent
return on an annual basis well right now
and it's it's very small right we're
talking about 20 billion dollars but
right now i can sell the forward bitcoin
futures contract in march i can buy some
bitcoin today with the promise to pay
and i can get a 9 10 yield right on an
annual basis and while that may not seem
like a lot um this has pretty big
implications as this market again grows
from say 20 billion to a lot larger
right uh the whole point is that there
is no central central planning committee
there is no uh chairman to decide these
rates and it's entirely free market
dependent right in april um you know
right before we had these massive
liquidations you could do this same kind
of trade where you sell this for futures
and you just buy bitcoin and you're
completely market neutral meaning you're
not dependent on the price going up or
down you're just yours flat you can
capture a 45 annual return so
the whole point is that um whether it's
perpetual swaps or quarterly futures uh
a lot of people get confused with
derivatives but the thing you have to
know is there's a really big problem in
the world it's that the cost of capital
is manipulated and planned uh and when
these with these basically completely
native
uh you know crypto derivative markets
bitcoin derivative markets um that's
changing and so while it may seem like
it's a hindrance to bitcoin's adoption
and the volatility isn't good what we
have are free and open markets and i
think that can't be stressed enough
i tend to think that it is uh very very
manipulated which you're doing a great
job of highlighting here but i just
don't think people quite understand how
severe it is uh joe john what questions
you guys got
um us dylan how do you think about all
the future gts going on like how would
you think about investing in one or not
investing in one
yeah i would i would think that i
wouldn't buy a futures etfs just because
there's there's a rolling kind of
component to it so um the futures
bitcoin futures tend to trade above the
price of spot um so to say you know for
the the example we just gave the march
uh futures contract is trading at uh you
know a little bit a thousand dollars
higher than than the spot price um but
you know the cmes uh or like the the
valkyrie etfs say is buying cme futures
and they're rolling it in the front
month futures every single month so
you're basically buying bitcoin higher
than its price
selling it and doing that every single
month and over the long term you even if
it you know basically kind of correlates
to the bitcoin performance you
underperform bitcoin itself um so i
would say for any kind of retail
investor uh to just figure out you know
how to buy a bitcoin and eventually take
custody yourself which you couldn't do
with a securitized product like a
futures etf uh but for someone that's
allocating capital on institutional
basis uh who can't go buy bitcoin on on
square or strike right uh it's a it's a
lot it's a just it's a you know the only
option they have really so uh i mean
it's good for overall adoption for big
players but i think the spot etf will be
a lot more optimal in that sense and
then what have you seen with on chain
with people moving coins on or off um
like in between hot and cold storage
yeah um you know we've seen kind of this
trend since march of 2020 of big
outflows from exchanges um there was
that was kind of the macro comp for this
exchange balance trend uh through the
2017 bull market coins were flying onto
exchanges um and since then we've kind
of seen the opposite um the last couple
months have stalled
but really i think you're seeing just
kind of this natural organic adoption of
people realizing that bitcoin is this
digital bearer asset and there is uh
this kind of sovereignty that you can
achieve with any other asset um and
aside from the financial side of things
which you know i tend to focus on a lot
it is really empowering that people can
hold all of their wealth to move
anywhere in the world and you know even
memorize 12 words in their head and just
take it with them so
that's definitely something encouraging
to see and um that also kind of has this
supply squeeze impact on the prices if
occurring uh you know with a lot of
people at once gotcha joe you got any
questions
yeah dylan do you have any like uh
i wouldn't call them like wild
predictions but any idea of something
that might be like a big catalyst for
the upcoming year i assume some some
easy ones would be like if uh an etf is
approved right if we get some more clear
idea around regulation if the u.s adopts
this in some way or if another country
adopts it like el salvador but is there
anything that i'm not thinking about
that you think could have a big impact
on price
yeah i think i think you nailed it a
little bit there um just with um a lot
of the stuff in this in the spaces is
narrative driven and you kind of see
fomo in sight with say uh what happened
after uh march of 2020 we chopped around
at 9 000 all summer uh an accumulation
was occurring under the surface and then
michael saylor comes down and says run a
bitcoin standard uh everyone should do
this you know you're sitting on melting
ice cubes
and that and then like a parabolic run
ensued and so i think you know
everyone's kind of bored at 45 000 which
would seem crazy just a year ago but i
think that you know the next kind of
things on the checklist are um you know
additional corporate adoption uh the
accounting standards that the gap
accounting standards could definitely
improve um so bitcoin's not treated as
an intangible asset uh that's one thing
um the next thing is i think uh you saw
ukele tweet out his predictions for 2022
and saying additional nation state
adoption uh and um i think there's gonna
be some exciting news at the bitcoin
conference uh that we'll see he'll be
there attending and so i would i would
expect to see some additional nations um
some additional corporations uh and a
lot of like pension funds and insurance
funds under the surface uh still just
kind of accumulating small positions
right because uh they're they're you
know in the game to to basically protect
and and hand out fiat denominated
liabilities over decade you know two
decades three decade long time horizons
um so bitcoin in that sense in a world
where real yields are negative across
the board bitcoin becomes very very
attractive so i think those are just a
few catalysts and i think uh once we see
kind of a big one the whole fomo stage
that we saw in late 2020 we'll we'll
pick back up again and then that's when
things get exciting
yeah do you think people uh leaders of
other countries are calling up you kelly
and just saying hey like how did you do
this give me the playbook
yeah i think there's there's definitely
a lot of eyeballs on on what he's doing
in his strategy especially for countries
that don't have their own currency yeah
right so kelly was on the dollar
standard um so you know he got
like he had you know all the like the
hardship of having basically uh foreign
reserves and and or operating on a
dollar standard but he couldn't get to
print it right so when the dollar uh
when the dollar value
really like skyrocketed in say you know
early early 2020 um and everyone was hit
across the board uh there was no way to
stimulate and so he said okay well i'm
not going to make my own crappy currency
um because no one will value it outside
of the people that i impose to use it
i'm just going to plug into this open
monetary standard
and you know potentially see the gains
through say you know harnessing untapped
energy sources and and basically you
know having people all over the world
that are now interested in in my little
country that weren't before um and so i
think there's definitely some sort of
game theory in play and though although
we haven't see it play out i think
there's definitely some interesting
discussions happening in the surface
because uh you know we aren't the only
ones paying attention here
dylan when you think about uh kind of
the conversation the sentiment on
twitter it seems like a lot of people i
don't want to say maybe they are getting
lulled to sleep but there's people who
are saying i don't know i don't know
what's happening to bitcoin it didn't
hit 100k by the end of the year what's
going on what's going on is that more
concerning to you or is that exactly
what you would expect before it makes
some big move and kind of breaks out
with some volatility in either direction
yeah i mean i think um you kind of
nailed it there it's definitely people
are getting a little bored a lot of
people expect a lot higher prices you
have people now calling for a lot of
lower prices um it's interesting just
kind of how sentiment can shift um we're
just you know say 12 months ago we were
euphoric as bitcoin broke 30 000
um and so it's important to kind of just
you know keep things uh you know just
have a little bit of uh a long time
horizon and understand what's at play
nothing has changed in terms of the
long-term bitcoin thesis and and if
anything it's it's never looked any
better and so we saw a lot of you know
pretty big things happen in 2021 uh the
taproot soft fork and and all these
other things that have been that have
been basically in the works for a long
long time and so sitting at 45 or 47 000
at the beginning of 2022
i'm a pretty ecstatic buyer and you know
even though the the charts may not be
too exciting nowadays uh you know
nothing has really changed in the
long-term game
makes sense
um my last question for you is uh
yesterday was bitcoin's birthday 13
years any uh takeaways from just like
how far we've come in 13 years
yeah i mean it's pretty astounding um
just thinking about the the foresight of
uh whoever whatever satoshi nakamoto
is
don't know if he's still around but it's
definitely one of the most you know
altruistic things that's really ever
been done uh in human history i think um
satoshi nakamoto is kind of this this
legendary figure that gifted something
to humanity and took back nothing in
return um you know
a million or so bitcoin estimated um
having never moved walked away from the
software project uh with with you know
with no claim to fame just
disappeared um you know giving us all uh
you know peaceful alternative to to fiat
currency and kind of the
by the money manipulation that's
occurred at scale for hundreds and
hundreds of years and so um in that
sense it's kind of a beautiful thing and
i think uh you know everybody should
should learn about the bitcoin protocol
and kind of figure out this thing and
how it can empower you uh january 3rd is
known as proof of keys day which is uh
basically you know to take bitcoin off
exchange hold it yourself um you know
establish your sovereignty to the
maximum degree and so i encourage
everyone to learn a little bit more
about that and it's definitely cool to
you know get another year in the books
i completely agree by the way you know
what else happened what sliding in right
before the end of the year
100k followers for dillon 100k yup
figures let's get it
next do you have a goal for this year
can we get to uh
100k
a million is probably difficult can you
get to 600k you think
uh i mean
hell i don't know maybe
we'll see uh 100k happened a lot faster
than i think i mean i don't really have
an objective goal for for twitter
followers i just kind of you know post
my thoughts and and then it happens so
it's cool to see definitely and it's
cool to interact with all these people
around the world
i had my first person come up to me and
approach me in the gym the other day and
that was an interesting uh what did they
say anything i was dude like dude i see
you on pomp's show that's so cool i was
like did you ask if they liked the
videos
did you ask them if they had the videos
like what's up with that
yeah it was like i watch them all i was
like damn that's that's pretty cool
you're like it was weird you tell them
you're like move over i gotta bench 500
now
you tell him i write newsletter deep
dive
did you get him on the newsletter
yeah
i i told him to sign up for the
newsletter as well no uh yeah do check
out if you like this kind of stuff we
post a lot of the
same you know stuff on derivatives and
on chain and macro data for the deep
dive uh it's in my bio so so give it a
check out we just put out our uh our
annual report for 2021. dylan are you
doing anything differently with your
personal position on bitcoin and
thoughts on bitcoin like how to allocate
capital to it in 2022 versus last year
um you know there's there's some things
i do kind of on the margin with you know
i i hold them a super majority of of my
i guess liquid net worth and cold
storage um you know depending on some of
the derivative data or some of the other
stuff i'll do
i'll do things that are a little more
complex like long or short volatility
and other stuff and options maybe which
you know i i don't really encourage many
people to do i just you know just just
stack and and there's no way you can
lose but um in terms of now no i expect
a little bit more consolidation uh for
the coming kind of weeks that was my my
base case in in decemberish uh so you
know i think we'll see a little bit more
chop before things uh heat up here but
uh nothing's really changed in terms of
my my personal allocation
all right
i don't know if we got anything else for
you man
i'm uh i'm impressed you uh you continue
to get better and better and uh your
analysis is pretty damn good it's like i
get like a front seat to a little
education every single week so i
appreciate you uh any plans this week
for uh kicking off the new year
um no no not much uh actually uh headed
uh to to nashville um with the with the
bm team we're gonna get together and and
you know make some quarterly plans so
that's exciting i'm excited to go get
out of the cold
all right man sounds good i'll see you
when you move to miami
see you guys